when I saw the previews for the
Emperor's New Groove I just said okay
I'm done no more Disney they have
clearly given up what David Spade is a
llama really this is your movie these
are the people that brought us Snow
White and Sleeping Beauty and The Lion
King and David Spade as a llama no just
no but after years and years of
everybody telling me you got to see the
average New Groove you got to see the
Emperor's New Groove I finally broke
down and I put it on and better than I
thought but I don't know if that makes
it good at least not for me well okay
let's talk about it David Spade plays an
emperor that's totally full of himself
in a complete jerk so an evil sorceress
and her bumbling sidekick trying to put
him out of his misery and take control
of the crowd but they accidentally
slipped him a potion that turns him into
a llama instead of killing him and well
they try kill him anyway but the
sidekick messes up and accidentally lets
him get away
so the llama comes across a peasant
played by John Goodman as you'd imagine
they don't get along they backstab one
another and yeah it's pretty much a
buddy buddy comedy do I even need to say
what's gonna happen in the end they're
gonna go on their road trip they're
gonna become friends they're gonna
figure out something about one another
and of course they're gonna defeat the
bad guys I guess what people really like
about this movie is all the adult humor
and fourth-wall jokes I guess a good
chunk of the time they do work I mean I
can't think of a joke swear I was just
smacking my head saying Oh God really
they said that but I can also think of
many jokes where I didn't laugh that
hard it's probably no secret I'm not a
big fan of David Spade and yeah I'd be
lying if I said I liked him a lot here
but much like Rosie O'Donnell and Tarzan
he's not that annoying John Goodman is
John Goodman yeah just serve his typical
nice guy you know it works but I've seen
it before the side characters I guess
are just the people they come across on
their journeys and I don't remember too
many of them but again I don't remember
ayiva being super annoying honestly I
just don't want to see Disney do a
buddy-buddy roadtrip movie I mean it's
me I'm expecting great big grand things
or if they are gonna do a comedy a great
big grand comedy if you want to see a
buddy-buddy roadtrip movie from them
that's fine but when I hear Disney I
think grand animation I think the best
of the best
not David Spade as oh ah ah so really I
think everything in this movie is just
kind of okay with the exception of one
element the villains Eartha Kitt and
Patrick Warburton are friggin hilarious
they make this movie every scene with
them makes me laugh and makes me laugh
hard it's such a peculiar team-up but
you know what it really works
the voices the expressions and
especially the animation on them are
just wonderful like that's something
that I should bring up the animation in
this as far as comedy goes is really
really good the timings really fast and
the line work is really good so I will
give the film credit for that but like I
said the only thing that really stands
up for me are the villains in fact I
really wish the movie was just about the
two of them but as is it's just your
typical buddy-buddy roadtrip movie like
I said and if you're looking for a
Disney version of that I guess you'll
like this fine but it doesn't do much
for me like I said not as bad as I
thought but just nothing spectacular for
me
boom baby